écoutez je ne vais pas vous répondre à
toutes ces questions ont plutôt dans le
jeu pas y répondre en détail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est nos services de
renseignement de la confédération cela
service de renseignement stratégique à
l'époque où j'y étais ils portaient un
autre nom il était plus militarisé
aujourd'hui il est beaucoup plus orienté
sur la menace terroriste
à l'époque où j'étais il était beaucoup
plus orienté sur la menace stratégique
militaire
évidemment on était en période de guerre
froide
je m'occupais du pack devoir celui de
toutes les forces vives de varsovie ou
ou qu'elles fussent dans le mode
d'ailleurs ça allait être une partie
d'un groupe
l'idée du service de renseignement ou sa
fonction principale était de prévenir
des les autorités gouvernementales d'une
éventuelle menace à l'époque où on sait
que l'union soviétique était capable
d'intervenir militairement en occident
dans un délai de 72 heures
je vais pas rentrer dans tous les
détails parce que beaucoup sont encore
classifiées mais je peux vous dire que
moi même j'ai été formé dans les
services américains et les services
britanniques
je les connais très bien et on avait des
contacts avec les services occidentaux
ce que des rapports parlementaires par
celui mentionné comme les services ali
qui était à l'époque je ne vous le cache
pas des gens qui étaient plutôt à
l'ouest vers et on en avait très peu
voire pas du tout à l'est du rideau donc
la suisse toujours resté neutre
politiquement mais en termes de
renseignement elle est toujours restée
très occidental aujourd'hui les choses
ont changé parce que les menaces sont
beaucoup plus orientés soutenir le
terrorisme
et là tout le monde se trouve un petit
peu concernés il ya plus de dsd d'ouest
à proprement parler
[Musique]
oui bien sûr à la ccl des informations
dans le but d'aider les activités dans
ce domaine financier mais probablement
beaucoup plus dans le cadre de la lutte
contre le blanchiment d'argent
à partir des années soixante dix la
suisse est clairement orienté dans
comment dans la lutte contre le
blanchiment d'argent entre défaut qui
aurait pu être cachée d'une manière ou
d'une autre que même échappé une
certaine manière ou au fisc même si
probablement aujourd'hui encore des
trous dans la passoire pendant celui-ci
une collaboration avec pratiquement tous
les pays européens
convoyer les services américains le fbi
aille à bureaux à berne donc les
services suisses travaillent main dans
la main sur la question du justement du
blanchiment ont bien deux de tous qui
toutes les activités criminelles qui
pourrait être lié à la aux activités
bancaires
c'est le réputation qui est en jeu c'est
leur crédibilité c'est leur capacité
aussi à pouvoir opérer dans des pays
amis un je parle notamment des statues
qui sont très rapides à imposer des
sanctions et à interdire à une banque
d'opérer sur leur territoire
si elle a des contacts ou des liens avec
des organisations terroristes criminels
ou autre c'est par conséquent c'est dans
l'intérêt des banques de se prémunir
contre ça
[Musique]
cet aperçu un usage que contrairement à
ce qu'on peut imaginer la part de deux
fours clandestins cachés ou d'origine
criminelle dans le système bancaire
suisse est beaucoup plus faible qu'on
pourrait l'imaginer en réalité
[Musique]
ayant probablement des pays qui sont
beaucoup plus intéressants contre des
organisations criminelles
la grande bretagne en est actuellement
des pays dé certains pays des caraïbes
qui sont beaucoup plus accueillant
entrée 10 mai pour comprendre des délais
des fous les ont pas très clair
[Musique]